Gordon Sunderland was considered a close
ally of President Trump's the 61 year
old businessman gave Trump's
inauguration committee a million dollars
became ambassador to the European Union
and is said to have had the president's
number on speed dial all that changed
after sunland's explosive testimony to
the president's handling of military aid
to Ukraine was there a quid pro quo as I
testified previously with regard to the
requested White House call and the White
House meeting the answer is yes
under the pivotal witness in the
impeachment Quarian to President Trump
was Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Vint
Minh a highly decorated soldier an
expert on Ukraine been man's testimony
was said to have enraged the president
is improper for the President of the
United States to demand a foreign
government investigate a US citizen and
a political opponent it was also clear
that if Ukraine pursued an investigation
into the 2016 elections the Biden's and
briefs m'a it would be interpreted as a
partisan play on Friday Lieutenant
Colonel VIN Minh and his twin brother a
lawyer at the National Security Council
were escorted from the White House by
officials both have been reassigned just
hours after the president commented on
the lieutenant-colonel it is midnight in
Washington senior figures in the
Democratic Party reacted angrily to the
firings Adam Schiff who took a lead role
in the president's impeachment tweeted
Lieutenant Colonel Vint Minh did his job
as a soldier in Iraq he received a
Purple Heart
then he displayed another rare form of
bravery moral courage he complied with a
subpoena and told the truth he upheld
his oath when others did not one of the
president's senior advisors said the
firing sent a clear message that not
backing the commander-in-chief will not
be tolerated
following the impeachment inquiry and
his acquittal it seems that President
Trump is bent on retribution woman's
lawyer released a statement saying the
most powerful man in the world buoyed by
the silent pliable and complicit has
decided to exact his revenge it came as
no surprise to many that two key
witnesses in what President Trump called
a hoax and now gone the question is
whose name
and again laka al Jazeera Washington